♪♪
>> Jesse: "THE WASHINGTON POST"
METHODING DOWN OVER A CANCEL
CULTURE FIRESTORM.
THE STEWART OF DEMOCRACY FACING
INTENSE BACKLASH OVER THEIR
REACTION TO AN EMPLOYEE'S
RETWEETED JOKE.
ON MONDAY, THE POST SUSPENDED
REPORTER DAVE WIEGLE FOR A MONTH
WITHOUT PAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
HE RETWEETED APOLOGIZED FOR IT
AND UNRETWEETED A SEXIST JOKE.
WE'LL SHOW YOU THE JOKE.
EVERY GIRL IS BY.
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT IF IT'S
POLAR OR SEXUAL.
ONE OF HIS COLLEAGUES SHARED A
SCREEN SHOT OF THE RETWEET AND
PUBLICLY CALLED HIM OUT FOR IT
ON TWITTER.
SINCE THEN, IT'S BEEN AWOKE
CIVIL WAR AT "WASHINGTON POST."
GREG, YOU'RE DELIGHTED IN THIS
STORY.
>> Greg: IT'S THE BEST STORY
EVER.
I DON'T THINK YOU GAVE IT
JUSTICE.
THEY'RE EATING EACH OTHER ALIVE.
THEY'RE CALLING EACH OTHER OUT
ON TWITTER, THIS IS WHAT HANS
WHEN ADULTS HAND THE REINS TO
CHILDREN.
THEY CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN REAL AND IMAGINED
MISERY.
BEZOS SHOULD SAY GROW UP BUT HE
WON'T.
HE'S TOO BUSY HANGING OUT WITH
THE NEW CHIC.
THIS IS THE PREDICT OF THE DEATH
OF BLUE COLLAR JOURNALISM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE NEWSROOM
DIDN'T HAVE COLLAGE DEGREES.
NOW THEY'RE OVERDIM DIPLOMAED,
RIGHT?
YOU DON'T SEE THIS ON A FACTORY
LINE OR CONSTRUCTION SITE.
YOU SEE IT WITH PEOPLE THAT ALL
THEY DO IS GO TO CLASS AND
COMPLAIN AND REPORT THEIR
PROFESSORS.
WAPO GOT SUCKERED BY PEOPLE THAT
GET ATTENTION ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
A JOURNALIST IS LOOKING FOR
OBJECTS TO BRING ATTENTION TO
IT.
ALL OF THESE HIRES ARE PEOPLE
USED TO HAVING PEOPLE CLICK,
CLICK, CLICK.
SO NOW THEY'RE EATING EACH OTHER
ALIVE.
THE REASON WHY IS YOU CAN'T
FIELD A UNIFIED TEAM WITH
EVERYONE THAT WANTS TO BE THE
CENTER OF ATTENTION.
THAT'S WHY WE WORK SO WELL HERE.
WE SHARE.
WE NEVER GO ON TWITTER.
I DON'T SAY -- I SAY EVERYTHING
TO PEOPLE'S FACES.
>> Jeanine: TO OUR FACE.
>> Jesse: SEEMS LIKE AT FOX WE
LIKE EACH OTHER HERE AND NOT SO
MUCH OVER THERE.
>> Dana: A COUPLE OF THINGS.
WHAT BEZOS SHOULD DO AND ALL
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS, FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE AT THE "WASHINGTON POST,"
THEY SHOULD SAY EVERYONE IS
BANNED FROM TWITTER FOR A MONTH.
EVERYONE.
THEN THEY CAN SORT OF TAKE IT
FROM THERE.
LET'S GET BACK TO DOING WORK.
ALSO, DO YOU REMEMBER BACK IN
THE DAY WHEN THE PERSON WHO WAS
THE SNITCH IS THE ONE THAT GOT
PUNISHED?
I LONG FOR THOSE DIES.
>> Greg: SNITCHES GET STITCHES,
DANA.
>> Dana: YEAH.
IF I SAID ANGIE DID THIS, YOUR
PARENTS ARE LIKE YOU NEED TO
MIND YOUR OWN BUSINESS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW.
WE NEED TO BRING SHAMING
SNITCHES BACK.
>> Dana: IT'S A SHIV.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
NEED TO MAKE EXAMPLES OUT OF
THEM.
TULSI?
>> Tulsi: TWISTED PRIORITIES.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" IS
SUPPOSEDLY ABOUT NEWS AND
JOURNALISM AND FACTS.
THEY'RE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
CANCEL CULTURE AND, YOU KNOW,
SUSPENDED WITHOUT PAY THIS GUY A
MONTH FOR RETWEETING A
COMEDIAN'S JOKE.
THEY'RE MORE CONCERNS ABOUT
TAYLOR LORENZ THAT WRITES FAKE
ARTICLES.
IT'S A SIGN OF THE TIMES TO SHOW
HOW FAR OFF TRACK "THE
WASHINGTON POST" HAS BECOME MORE
OF A PROPAGANDA ORGANIZATION
THAN NEWS ORGANIZATION.
>> Jesse: HOW WOULD YOU HAVE
HANDLED WIEGLE?
>> Jeanine: IN MY OFFICE, IF
PEOPLE START FIGHTING WITH EACH
OTHER, YOU GET ALONG OR YOU'RE
BOTH OUT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THIS
PETTY NONSENSE.
YOU HAVE A JOB TO DO.
>> Greg: THEY'RE NOT ADULTS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: WAS THE JOKE FUNNY?
>> Jeanine: NO.
>> Dana: I LAUGHED.
>> Greg: YOU SAID IT WAS FUNNY
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
>> Jeanine: YOU LIKE, GREG
GUTFELD.
I'LL NEVER DANCE WITH YOU AGAIN.